[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le
grand jt des territoires sur vos chaînes
locales et régionales et sur tv5 monde
voici les titres de l'actualité un
nouveau dispositif contre la copie de 19
le premier vaxy drive a ouvert cette
semaine ses portes près de montpellier
via occitanie nous montrera qu'il est
pratique de se faire vacciner
tout en restant au volant de sa voiture
aux antilles l'aide s'organise après
l'entrée en éruption du volcan de la
soufrière sur la petite île de saint
vincent et les grenadines près de la
martinique des milliers d'habitants ont
dû évacuer leur logement
les précisions dans ce journal avec la
rédaction de via à tv sur place un
cadeau prestigieux pour le prince albert
de monaco
le souverain ajoute la formule 1 de 2019
du pilote charles leclerc à sa
collection personnelle et la rédaction
de monaco info a pu assister à cette
donation exceptionnelle
enfin à la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires nous nous étendrons avec une
nouvelle méthode venue du japon le bain
de forêt le premier site a été labellisé
en gironde
découverte avec la rédaction de télé 7
la chaîne du groupe sud ouest se faire
vacciner sans sortir de sa voiture c'est
le premier titre de ce journal c'est le
concept prometteur aussi du tout premier
vaxy drive ouvert cette semaine près de
montpellier
très pratique ce nouveau dispositif doit
permettre d'accélérer la campagne de
vaccination la prise de rendez-vous ne
change pas et se fait toujours sur
internet
écoutez les précisions avec ce reportage
de patrick mallet devient occitanie sur
place bonjour alors c'est sûrement pas
de vaccination venant d'agde jusqu'à la
clinique saint-jean à montpellier lesieu
sabatier et le nez tout premier en
france à se faire vacciner sans sortir
de sa voiture
moi jamais
aller chercher une place au parking tout
ça et où on arrive à se reprendre aux
allemands ça c'est beau tout ça y est
c'est fait ma fille a pris rendez-vous
pour moi je découvre aujourd'hui le
dispositif mille personnes sont
aujourd'hui vaccinés par semaine dans
cette clinique
l'ouverture de ce maxi drive devrait
permettre de vacciner le double c'est un
peu comme si nous venions venions vous
vacciner chez vous voilà la voiture
c'est comme un domicile donc voilà on a
voulu simplifier et et faire en sorte
que cette vaccination soit accessible à
tous pour gagner la guerre contre la
pandémie il fallait intensifier et la
vaccination et on a réfléchi à toutes
les pistes qui pourraient nous permettre
de vacciner plus et on a vu ce qui se
passait dans d'autres pays comme aux
états unis où effectivement il existe
déjà des vagues si drive et je pense que
ça c'était bon exemple et on a voulu
faire un petit peu commun c'est à dire
faire des choses simples efficaces avec
10 millions de primo vaccinées à ce jour
les vaccine ride s'il se développe
devrait permettre la montée en puissance
de la vaccination en france l'objectif
affiché du gouvernement est en atteindre
les 30 millions de français vaccinés
d'ici la fin du mois de juin
il fallait le faire on l'a fait on est
tranquille c'est ça oui il faut que ce
genre de cette pandémie quand même
moment qu'on va paraissait cinquantaine
pour nous ça et c'est l'autre grande
nouveauté dans la bataille contre le
coronavirus les autotests sont arrivés
cette semaine en pharmacie dans les
yvelines les premières livraisons se
sont tout de même fait un peu attendre
comme a pu le constater au nord sinoquet
de tv 78 dans les yvelines donc le
gouvernement a annoncé qu'il avait droit
d'être vendues en pharmacie à partir du
je vais pas dire qu'ils seront présentes
en acier partie de nuit des autotests de
la coc u19 qui se font attendre dans les
officines en ce premier jour
d'autorisation de vente les clients vont
donc devoir patienter
on va pouvoir leur dire prochainement ce
qu'on n'a pas encore les tests on peut
pas s'avancer maintenant à les prix on a
acquis on peut les donner donc c'est
déjà une bonne chose qu'on puisse
répondre quelque chose aux patients dès
réception de leur commande les
pharmacies vendrons ces auto test une
trentaine d'euros par lot de 5 pour le
propriétaire de la pharmacie de l'espace
saint quentin pas sûr que ses clients
adhèrent les jambes en l'air de vouloir
se précipiter pour acheter les autotests
sachant que les tests anti génie
classique sont gratuits sont battus à
payer de leur poche
donc ils préfèrent faire les tests
antigénique classique plutôt d'acheter
les autotests qui se vendit par 5 vous
alentours de 30 euros la boîte payant
pour le grand public mais la sécurité
sociale pourra prendre en charge ce coup
notamment pour les personnes travaillant
avec des personnes âgées ou handicapées
s'est auto test devrait donc arriver
dans le courant de la semaine dans les
pharmacies yvelinoise les premières
semaines des vacances d'avril se termine
en france des vacances vous le savez
réaménagé pour contrôler l'épidémie sur
tout le territoire
alors que de nombreux français ont dû
rester chez eux avec leurs enfants
d'autres ont eu la chance de s'exiler
c'est notamment le cas de retraités près
de rennes qui ont décidé de passer le
confinement au camping reportage de
philippe berthaut pour nos partenaires
de tvrl le camping des chevrets à
saint-coulomb compte 284 résidents
propriétaires de leur mobile home
mais seuls 10 d'entre eux ont choisi d'y
passer le confinement c'est le cas pour
ces jeunes retraités sarthois
bénéficie ici d'une magnifique vue sur
la manche et sur l'île bénard en dire
autant en profiter d'être à la guy moret
qu'est un site assez chouette c'est
chouette pour nous hors bord de mer donc
on va essayer d'en profiter pendant un
mois donc on prépare la saison ont fait
un grand nettoyage comme d'habitude et
là on prend de temps même démarche pour
lydie qui venu ici avec ses petits
enfants profiter du grand air pour elle
son mobile home à tous les avantages
d'une résidence secondaire
vraiment tout ce qu'il nous faut un
confort en un chauffage à parce que
quand même les nuits c'est un peu
frisquet mais quand le soleil est là
c'est génial on a tout ce qu'il faut et
un jardin est allé à tout ce qu'il faut
la plage de sa cote est un lieu de rêve
ici conséquence du confinement
les clients habitués du début de saison
notamment les étrangers au camping coeur
ne sont pas venus ainsi une partie du
personnel du camping a été placé sous le
régime de l'activité partielle en
attendant la fin du mois d'avril
la grosse période intéressante pour nous
au mois de mai c'est au tour de l'est
pont de l'ascension donc ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut pas
qu'on rate je suis tanné le camping des
chevrets compte au total 600
emplacements dont 75 mobile homes
disponibles à la location aux antilles
l'aide humanitaire en provenance de la
martinique arrive progressivement à
saint vincent
alors que le volcan est toujours en
éruption là bas les 45 tonnes de
matériel d'eau potable et de vivres
convoyés par l'armée mardi soir sont
arrivés à bon port
l'heure est au déchargement sur place
les envoyés spéciaux de via à tv
martinique
loïc régis et jean-marc d'abreu
l'afrique at ventôse est bien arrivé ici
à kingston à saint-vincent vous le savez
nous sommes parti de fort-de-france avec
dans les soutes du matériel notamment de
l'eau à destination de la population qui
on a besoin depuis les éruptions de la
soufrière
alors on espère faire ça en cinq heures
on verra ça va dépendre un petit peu de
beaucoup de choses c'est tout va tout de
suite être distribués aux sinistrés
écoutez les précisions et d'une
représentante de la croix rouge de saint
vincent
c'est elle qui est
l'organisation de la distribution de
l'eau nous organisons la distribution
logistique avec la compagnie de l'eau et
les autorités ils nous disent où il n'y
a absolument pas d'eau dans le pays et
l'ue dirigeons les camions et chargement
ce matin vers les communes et vers les
gens qui ont un besoin critique d'eau
ils vont aussi prendre et 25 mètres
cubes d'eau du bateau et les distribuer
aux citernes qui partent vers les
maisons
il y à l'aide française mais aussi
l'aide d'autres territoires de la
caraïbe notamment le venezuela mais
aussi trinidad et qui apporte en plus
d'eau aussi des groupes électrogènes qui
permettront de pallier les difficultés
dans de production d'électricité sur
l'île une nouvelle éruption a frappé
l'île de saint vincent avec de nouvelles
retombées de cendres notamment sur le
nord de l'île nous vous en parlions déjà
la semaine dernière dans le grand jt des
territoires le gel a fait beaucoup de
dégâts dans les vergers et les vignobles
français dans la loire notamment sur
certaines parcelles comme le pilat 80 %
de la récolte pourrait être perdue pour
aider le monde agricole le gouvernement
à déclarer l'état de calamité agricole
et promis d enveloppe exceptionnelle
adrien bletterie de tl7 s'est rendu à
marc si le châtel pour rencontrer un
vigneron très touché regardez
maxime gillier possède 18 hectares de
vignes à marcy le châtel ce jeune
viticulteur se souviendra du jeudi 8
avril 2021 les -6° constaté au lever du
soleil ont détruit plus de 50% des
bourgeons qui était sur le point
d'éclore peut-être que les 50 % qui
restent
et il y aura pas mieux donc donc
peut-être que ça va être 0 bah on voit
la 1 2 3 4 5 6 6 sur 10
ça fait 60 % de perte 60% sur cette
branche là mais le véritable pourcentage
de perte pourrait être rétablie dans
deux semaines environ dans tous les cas
le vin se fera plutôt rare en 2022
là c'est la vendange 2021 donc le temps
de faire le vin et cetera de l'élever
loc ils arrivent sur le marché au
printemps en 2022
donc les gens ont plus en tête cet
épisode de gel et comprennent pas qu'il
n'y ait pas de 20 à ce moment là donc la
perte elle est commerciale aussi en fait
le gouvernement a activé le régime de
calamité agricole pour soutenir toutes
les cultures mais les subventions qui
seront versées ne semble pas totalement
satisfaire les viticulteurs pour ce qui
es vont pouvoir acheter du raisin ou
pour les pour les autres cultures
c'est bien d'être d'être classé après
nous en vignes je crois que le jalil et
général donc ça va être serré difficile
pour tout le monde et la situation
semble très délicate dans toute la loire
plusieurs viticulteurs du département
pense déjà à réduire fortement le nombre
de saisonniers pour les prochaines
vendanges
une autre inquiétude à présent celle des
taxis et des vtc français près de la
frontière suisse
ils s'opposent depuis quelques jours au
durcissement de leur possibilité de
circuler sur le canton de genève
notamment une directive limite en effet
leur activité à 90 jours par an et les
oblige à déclarer huit jours au
préalable les courses effectuées sur
tout le territoire suisse
une obligation légale impossible à
respecter pour certaines courses selon
eux pour se faire entendre ils ont
occasionné des dizaines de kilomètres de
bouchons aux abords des quatre
principales douane franco genevoise des
images de nos partenaires locaux de 8
mont blanc sur place
des images rares maintenant dans ce
grand jt des territoires avec la force
barkan de l'armée française qui poursuit
sa mission au mali une mission souvent
contestée ces derniers temps quant à son
coût financier et humain des soldats du
1er régiment de tirailleurs d'epinal
vient d'ailleurs de faire leur retour
dans les vosges
après quatre mois
d'une mission marquée par une attaque
terroriste qui a blessé en janvier
dernier
neuf soldats spinaliens une équipe de
vie à gauche a rencontré le chef de
corps et quelques tirailleurs reportage
de thierry glaçons et de denis lequel le
caporal-chef dylan fait partie des neuf
tirailleurs d'epinal qui ont été dans le
cadre de l'opération barkan blessé le 8
janvier dernier au mali lors d'une
attaque terroriste au véhicule piégée
contre un convoi franco-malien
l'adrénaline prend le dessus donc on
essaye de rester vif on essaie de rester
de rester lucide et puis on fait ce
qu'on a à faire au mieux
on y pense encore après on peut pas dire
le contraire s'ils ne s'étaient pas
interposés avec leur véhicule blindé de
combat d'infanterie entre le véhicule
suicide et le reste du convoi
il recruterait probablement plusieurs
plusieurs mans crise sanitaire oblige
pas de cérémonie mais une délégation
était reçue ce vendredi matin l'hôtel de
ville d'epinal une manière de marquer
symboliquement l'attachement historique
de la cité des images à son régiment et
le retour de ce dernier après quatre
mois d'une mission exigeante de par les
conditions climatiques et géographiques
et le rôle à tenir socialement
économiquement auprès de la population
africaine
la formation de l'armée malienne et la
lutte de chaque jour contre des
groupuscules islamistes
nous sommes très fiers lui d'avoir
démantelé trois ateliers de confection
d'engins explosifs improvisés qui vous
savez demeure la la menace principale au
mali sous le commandement du colonel
vouilloux le groupement tactique des
airs l'ami une force de frappe de 800
hommes dont les deux tiers sont
tirailleurs basée à gossi à environ 400
kilomètres de tombouctou et pas très
loin devant boris la région où s'est
déroulée la tacc elle est vitale sur le
terrain la logistique armes et véhicules
matériels et denrées alimentaires à
titre d'exemple 9 litres d'eau par jour
sont nécessaires par militaire
aucun nouveau départ n'est programmé à
l'heure actuelle pour le premier et
retire qui va participer aux missions
sentinelle dans le cadre de vigipirate
renforcé le régiment qui espère pouvoir
organiser une véritable cérémonie
officielle de retour le 7 mai prochain
si les conditions sanitaires le
permettent
et puis c'est l'une des conséquences
malheureuses de la période actuelle les
violences conjugales ont explosé au
cours des divers confinement et au delà
de la nécessaire répression tout l'enjeu
est d'éviter la récidive
à nantes comme vous pouvez le voir sur
ces images des stages de
responsabilisation sont organisées pour
les auteurs de violences conjugales
les intervenants socio judiciaire les
encadrent pour leur rappeler la loi des
images de nos partenaires de télénantes
sur place
l'économie à présent dans nos régions
avec michel picaud bonjour michel cette
semaine nous partons à dax pour
découvrir une manufacture elle s'appelle
la manufacture castex et cette pme qui
confectionne depuis plus de 150 ans des
couettes haut de gamme a fait le choix
aujourd'hui de vendre uniquement sur
internet bonjour sert il bonjour à tous
fêter son 150e anniversaire en 2020
était compliqué la manufacture castex a
donc décidé de célébrer dignement cet
anniversaire cette année en 2021
spécialiste des plumes et des duvets
l'entreprise familiale implantée à dax
depuis 1870 cinq générations à la tête
d'ailleurs confectionne des couettes
édredon oreiller et traversant et quand
on est installé dans le sud ouest de la
france au coeur de la plus grande région
d'élevage de cadars d'europe et bien
castex utilise naturellement les plumes
et duvets souple produits localement
pour élaborer ses propres produits
nous sommes donc ici sur du circuit
court et l'entreprise vend en direct
depuis sa boutique en ligne
ils ont arrêté de fournir les grands
acteurs du secteur pas assez rentable
pour des produits haut de gamme
toutefois en supprimant les
intermédiaires ils ont des prix d'usiné
reste donc très compétitif c'est
audacieux car le marché de la couette et
très concurrentiel et ce qui est
remarquable dans cette entreprise c'est
sa formidable agilité en 1870 il
traitait déjà le duvet mais sans faire
de couette
cent ans plus tard dans les années 80
c'est le bout
de la couette en france qui débarque en
force et chasse nos bonnes vieilles
couvertures aujourd'hui sachant que nous
sommes tous sensibles à la qualité de
notre sommeil
en même temps nous passons un tiers de
notre temps au lit et bien une surf sur
le haut de gamme à prix d'usiné c'est
bien vu alors je vous entends d'ici
comment se démarquer quand on porte le
même nom que le premier ministre
français pour ses 150 ans la manufacture
alphonse castex et son vrai nom s'est
trouvé un nouveau slogan la plume le
sommeil les 100 sièges merci michel
picaud au rendez vous dans un prochain
grand jt des territoires pour écorégions
tout à fait autre chose dans l'actualité
maintenant je vous le disais dans les
titres de ce journal la première formule
1 ferrari de charles leclerc a rejoint
la collection du prince albert de monaco
l'occasion pour le pilote monégasque de
marquer l'événement avec la visite du
souverain
un reportage princier de vanessa de 6 et
de lionel bernardi pour monaco info
regardez c'est au petit matin dans la
plus grande discrétion que l'opération a
été menée avec précision une livraison
spéciale est arrivé à la collection de
voitures de son altesse sérénissime le
prince de monaco
la ferrari sf 90 piloté par charles
leclerc lors de la saison 2010 9 a élu
domicile
officiellement aux terrasses de
fontvieille en fait charles leclerc est
venu pendant les fêtes de noël à notre
exposition antoine le pilote et il fait
à ce moment là qu'il m'a dit que une de
ses voitures allait lui être donnée donc
il m'a demandé est ce qui serait
possible d'envisager de la mettre dans
la collection de voitures de son altesse
sérénissime le prince de monaco
engagé par la scuderia ferrari charles
leclerc réalise deux victoires et dix
podiums avec cette formule 1 il est le
pilote ayant réalisé le plus grand
nombre de pole positions en 2019 pour le
monégasque que l'arrivée de sa monoplace
en principauté évoque une vive émotion
j'ai exaucer tous mes rêves en fait avec
avec 7 fm pas tous mais presque première
victoire en formule 1 première fois en
tant que pilote ferrari à la fin des
années 50 le prince rainier iii
passionné d'automobile début de sa
collection de voitures anciennes
au fil des années et des acquisitions la
collection s'agrandit c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui cette forme l'un trouve
naturellement sa place
ce formidable qu'elle puisse rejoindre
la collection mais que voilà que ça
qu'on continue dans cette dans cette
thématique la collection de voitures de
son altesse sérénissime le prince de
monaco est actuellement fermée au public
à noter donc que dès la réouverture les
visiteurs auront l'opportunité
d'approcher cette formule 1 qui ouvre un
nouveau chapitre de l'histoire
automobile en principauté voilà mais
ceux là vont beaucoup moins vite qu'une
formule 1 mais n'en sont pas moins utile
en normandie vous allez le voir la sncf
s'engage aux côtés des régions pour
sortir du diesel d'ici 2035
depuis le 6 avril 15 trains quotidiens
entre paris et granville carbure donc
pas au pétrole mais au colza
l'explication avec ce reportage d'eric
terrier hermann pour lcn la chaîne
normande
c'est une première en france le train
paris granville va rouler au
biocarburant à base de colza et se
passer du diesel une expérimentation de
trois mois lancé avec la région
normandie propriétaire des rames une
solution qui permet de réduire de façon
importante les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre explique la sncf
la graine de colza est à la fois riche
en huile est riche en protéines
cette caractéristique permet de produire
à la fois des tourteaux pour
l'alimentation animale de l'huile
alimentaire et des biocarburants
la flotte des 15 régiolis nomades a été
retenue pour ce test grandeur nature qui
durera jusqu'en juin 2021
une expérimentation qui permet d'évaluer
l'impact de ce carburant alternatif
durable sur le matériel et son
utilisation
donc aujourd'hui on a identifié 0 impact
sur la maintenance
c'est à dire que les rames vont
continuer à circuler tel que c'est prévu
au niveau de la trame de maintenance on
aura un suivi beaucoup plus poussée en
terme de
danalyse et de comportement du moteur
diesel plusieurs proches et d'innovation
sont en cours pour baisser d'un tiers
l'empreinte carbone des passagers même
économiquement j'ai l'impression que
c'est une meilleure solution d'utiliser
un carburant un peu plus locale qui
vient de l'agriculture le baissant pour
être une solution transitoire il nous
permettrait de sortir à très court terme
des énergies fossiles le matériel
roulant existant avant l'arrivée de
nouvelles technologies comme le train
hybride le train batterie ou le train
hydrogène
nous nous rendons dans le gers
maintenant où le paisible village de
ligardes est devenu en quelques années
un haut lieu de la magie blanche dans
l'ancienne ferme familiale le maire de
la commune pierre dulong a décidé de
consacrer sa vie à combattre les forces
occultes
pourtant rien ne destinait l'ancien
enfant de choeur
réélu aux dernières élections
municipales à devenir la bête noire de
satan ou de belzébuth un témoignage
recueilli par clément gaci pour notre
partenaire la dépêche du midi sur place
il ya des fois que quand deux
personnages en bois ne citer que les
posséder la suite de suite par rapport à
ces super content comportements et des
fois on pensait le simple un simple
envoûtement et elle est possédée
il faut dire une chose que des mots il
est très très très malade qui pousse à
mon appel je valais à paris maintenant
des habitants commémorer récemment la
commune de paris un épisode historique
et à visée sociale qui a débuté en mars
1871 et qui aura duré deux mois dans la
capitale
cette déambulation captées par les
caméras de télé bocal lisez notamment à
rendre hommage au rôle des femmes lors
de cette insurrection est une autre page
de l'histoire dans ce grand jt des
territoires à limoges cela se passe
une ville créative de l'unesco la
commune est au service du chemin de
saint jacques de compostelle
le pèlerinage actuel qui passe par le
centre ville à partir du pont
saint-etienne va être doublée d'un autre
itinéraire via le pont saint martial
l'objectif est là bas de profiter des
bords de la vienne pas cision sur place
de nos amis de la rédaction de 7 à
limoges des chemins de saint jacques de
compostelle traverse
centre ville de limoges on met un nouvel
itinéraire sera proposé balisé par des
coquilles en porcelaine jaune et bleu
c'est un petit trésor ce carton le ce
qui s'est passé c'est un peu fort mais
c'est fait un travail par rapport au
chemin de compostelle et pas plus grands
protège intéressant cette idée mais en
fait elle a démarré par l'association en
elle même qui nous a contactés
et qui voilà qui souhaitait en effet
pouvoir développer davantage
les influences dans la ville de limoges
à travers ce chemin de saint-jacques
très joli passage que nous avons
actuellement mais aussi de l'utilité de
l'importance peut-être d'avoir un autre
itinéraire
justement qui permettait d'avoir un
autre aspect plastique
l'itinéraire proposera un cheminement
sur les bords de vienne au pied de la
cathédrale saint-etienne le repaire du
chemin centre ville reste la coquille en
métal et passons à l'atelier pour se
baigner pour la nouvelle version saas et
socialement l'original c'est le modèle
c'est ce qui a servi réellement à faire
le moule pour pouvoir tirer les
premières pièces en porcelaine
on devrait voir apparaître la conclusion
fonctionnel actuellement en phase de
décors l'écho qui devrait être posée
dans le courant du mois de mai prochain
et sur la commune de l'île rousse en
corse des fous les archéologiques porté
par les services de l'état avec
l'institut national de recherches
archéologiques ont permis de mettre à
jour une nécropole datant des 3ème et
6ème siècle de notre ère
une découverte évidemment rare et
historique une quarantaine de tombes ont
ainsi été trouvés les défunts sont
inhumés majoritairement dans des
amphores provenant de tunisie les
détails au micro de pierre pasqualini
journalistes via télévisée pour nous ça
se rapproche de ce qu'on appelle
l'antiquité tardive avec des inhumations
en amphore les fausses qui sont aménagés
avec des tuiles de taigu les à l'île
rousse et les premiers vestiges
archéologiques qui sont retrouvés et si
nous nous défendions un peu maintenant
durant cette période stressante
grâce à un bain de forêt le chinois
youku traduit en français par ben de
forêt est une pratique médicinales
japonaise considéré comme une thérapie
naturelle contre le stress
le département de la gironde a décidé de
l'inscrire au programme de ces
animations nature alors qu'au japon une
soixantaine de bain de forêt existe la
france accueille son premier certifié à
hostens ce reportage de margarita
gorowyn pour la chaîne tv7 la cheffe du
groupe sud ouest en gironde
écoutez
touché contempler éveiller ses sens au
contact de la nature à hostens 600
hectares d'arbres et de lacs ont été
certifiés comme ben de forêt c'est une
marche lente sensorielle de trois heures
dans les bois l'objectif d'un mode forêt
c'est d'avoir une action de la forêt sur
la santé mentale et physique
mais ici on est dans un dans un site
naturel qui est d'une grande qualité
naturaliste environnementale de pureté
de l'air de son et tout ça ça concourt à
faire de la forêt un allié thérapeutique
pour notre santé le site a été validé
par l'institut national de forêts et de
médecine ses bienfaits sur la santé sont
prouvés un bain de forêt réduit le
stress surtout en cette période de
qu'ovide les conditions d'enfermement de
confinement et les menaces sur la santé
font qu'on est tenu de se re calme et de
rester très serein d'améliorer notre
santé physique en respirant en prenant
des bains de forêt justement ça peut
nous aider
depuis trois ans le service
environnement du département de la
gironde travailler pour inscrire cette
pratique
au programme de ces animations nature ce
projet de ban forêt est né dans le cadre
de notre campagne de résilience de nos
politiques environnementales ou
effectivement c'est on s'est interrogé
sur la place majeure qu'occupe l'arbre à
la fois dans le coup dans notre
quotidien mais aussi dans nos missions
est effectivement l'interdépendance
entre la nature et la santé
les organisateurs prévoient deux visites
guidées par mois les bains de forêt sont
gratuits il suffit de s'inscrire sur le
site internet du département et se
rendre à la forêt dust ans et des images
commande maintenant pour terminer ce
grand jt des territoires avec le mois de
jeûne du ramadan qui a commencé ce mardi
13 avril un mois de prière et de
réflexion pour les musulmans marquée
également par une alimentation
particulière et les traditionnelles
pâtisseries orientales à marseille
makrout l'okoumé cornes de gazelle font
déjà saliver le mois de ramadan qui a
lieu une nouvelle fois dans le contexte
particulier lié à la pandémie s'achèvera
par l'aïd el fitr la fête de la rupture
du jeûne qui aura lieu donc le
mais c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci à tous de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve bien sûr pour une
nouvelle édition a très vite tu es bon
courage à tous
[Musique]